hi I'm Ryan Broussard don't forget to
watch the new Fox series alert now
streaming on Hulu the missing person
unit means the world to Mike he's drawn
to save people dealer went out nine
minutes after she was taken Ryan brazard
vibrant and really talented Ryan is such
a sweetheart you get all the mic vibes
from him FYI I'm team Mike
was assigned to find Nikki and Jason's
son I don't understand any search for
other people's kids and we never found
ours
Mike now is in a relationship with Nikki
so they take it personally because they
know exactly what that feels like it was
my case my responsibility I related so
much to Mike he's always wanted to serve
the community all we need is a name we
gotta hit alert is so electric the
missing person unit is discovering
things at the same time as the audience
kidnapper might still be in the area
it's going to keep the audience on the
edge of their seat I got a location
we're almost out of time
I can't let you walk away you know that
foreign
[Music]